التفتوا للجنوب بدل تركيزكم على القتال
الوحشي شرقا منذ اشهر وتحديدا في بخموت
رساله بعث بها المسؤولون الامريكيون
والغربيون لكيف فحوها دعوه لاوكرانيا
لتغير من تكتيكاتها الحربيه في ساحه
المعركه دعوه تستبق قدوم فصل الربيع الذي
يبدو وفق حسابه الغرب موعدا لهجوم روسيا
واسع محتمل
لعله هنالك ما يحفز لتغيير بوصله كيف
الاسلوب المختلف من القتال من شانه ان
يستفيد من زخم المعدات العسكريه الجديده
التي تصيرها تباعا من الولايات المتحده
ودول الاوروبيه واقر لقاء ورمشتاين الاخير
تعزيزها ففي الجبهه الشرقيه نقلت سينا عن
مسؤول استخداماته الغربي كبير انا منذ ما
يقرب من سته اشهر كانت القوه الاخرانيه
ترابح في معاركها مع الروس في بخموت على
طول 36 ميلا وقال انها معركه وحشيه واحده
حيث تتبادل كل طرف ما بين 400 متر من
الارض يوميا كما تبادل الالاف من قبائل في
المدفعيه يوميا تقريبا
التركيز على التخطيط لهجوم في الجنوب قد
يساعد كيف على تجنب معركه الاستنزاف
الضاريه هذه لكن الرئيس الاوكراني لا
يعتقد ان انتصار روسيا في بخنوت امر واقع
فهي رمز مهم للمقاومه الاوكرانيه من وجهه
نظره يعني فوز روسيا فيها منحها فرصه
لتقدم اكثر الى المدن الشرقيه ذات اهميه
الاستراتيجيه في كل من سفيانس وكريموسك
واستعاده زمام المبادره في الحرب قد تدفع
بوتين وفق مسؤولين غربيين وامريين لتعبئه
اخرى للقوات تصل الى 200,000 رجل
قبل ايام قال مسؤول عسكري امريكي كبير ان
روسيا دفعت بعشره الاف من القوات البديله
سيئه التجهيز وغير المدرب على حد وصفه ولم
يغير ذلك من ديناميه القتال لكن اوكرانيه
تعاني ايضا من خسائر فادحه في المعركه
وتنفق كميه هائله من ذخيره المدفعيه يوميا
وهو اسلوب قتال لا تعتقد الولايات المتحده
انه مستدام لهذا تاتي الضغوط عليها لتغيير
تكتكاتها وتبدو النوايا اكثر وضوحا لشان
هجوم روسي او صعاب تعيين رئيس الاركان
العمل القوات المسلحه الروسيه
قائدا مباشره للحرب ووفقا سنان نقلا عن
مسؤولين عربي
استهداف العاصمه في مره اخرى وفقهم
ويرشحون ان تواصل روسيا تركيز معظمه
اهتمامها على الاستر على المزيد من
الاراضي انطلاقا من بخموت وفي من منطقه
زبوجيا والحفاظ على البريد من منطقه
يوستوف الى شبه جزيره القرم بين خطط هجوم
الربيع الروسي المحتمل ودعوات غربيه
لاوكرانيه لتغيير تكتكاتها وخطتها
العسكريه تقترب الحرب الروسيه على
اوكرانيا من طيعها الاول